today on the matt walsh show the daily
wires legal fight against the bite
administration officially begins and the
media claims that the results of
virginia were the product of white
grievance and white backlash and well
they're not totally wrong plus pfizer's
vaccine is now officially available to
kids as young as five the big question
is will a mandate be next and what will
happen if they try that and mental
health experts are finally admitting
that masking has done psychological
damage to people i'm old enough to
remember when such claims were dangerous
anti-science misinformation we'll talk
about all that much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i want to mention this right at the
top before we get to our opening topic
the by the administration's tyrannical
vaccine mandate will
be officially going into effect on
january 4th right after the holidays
biden's a christmas present to the
country
is a total deprivation of your rights
being a sadistic freak like he is he
would like to see thousands of americans
lose their jobs right at the beginning
of the new year that's what that's what
um you know that's what would bring him
the most holiday cheers to see that now
as you know here at the daily wire we
are not taking this lying down we're not
going to submit to this oppression and
this is not a game or a promotional
stunt it would be really easy for us to
comply with the mandate while still
protesting it on our shows and you know
talking about how terrible it all is uh
gee this is this is this is too bad i
mean we we have no choice but uh we
really don't like it
that's what a lot of companies are going
to do that's what they are doing
but verbal protest
means nothing if it comes alongside
acquiescence
begrudging acquiescence is still
acquiescence you could go along
with what you're being told and shake
your fist and and shake your head and
say yes and scowl while you're doing it
but if you're acquiescing if you're
submitting then that's all they care
about
our legal action against the
administration is being filed today
it's going to be an expensive fight but
a worthwhile one i mean this in many
ways is the fight this is one of the
greatest threats to our freedom that we
currently face
or that we have ever seen in our
lifetimes which is no exaggeration what
that means is that we need all the help
we can get
it's already cost us tens of thousands
of dollars just to prepare the case it
could easily cost us hundreds of
thousands or even millions in the future
if we're going to win this thing and we
plan on winning it so if you want to
join the fight and be a part of this
legitimately historic moment then become
a daily wire member i get messages from
people all the time asking how they can
support us and and this is the answer
become a member you can use code do not
comply get 25 discount as well when you
do uh become a part of the team and it
really is a team we made a difference in
virginia
we changed the landscape there
something that even the media uh the
corporate media is admitting and we'll
talk more about that in the five
headlines
well now we can take the fight to the
federal government we're going even
bigger this time and we can win there
too but uh we need your help so again
become a daily wire member today use
code do not comply
and join join us
all right on to the main topic for today
democrats to include the media
continue to lick their wounds and
attempt to formulate some sort of
rationalization for their party's
overwhelming defeat on tuesday night
they've of course settled on the racial
answer as they always do which was
pretty easy because that's the answer to
every question that the leftist mind
might ask
and as we discussed yesterday was it was
immediately decided that the voters in
virginia are all racist
which is why they voted against the
white man terry mcauliffe and for the
black female lieutenant governor win
some sears you know racism is funny that
way apparently
we played some clips on the on the of
the media connection fit yesterday but
grabian has put together a nice and
succinct compilation
uh so let's let's just take a trip down
memory lane and watch some of this again
glen younkin played the race card for a
reason because he knows it works on
certain white voters he did stoke white
grievance politics to mobilize the
republican base he's laundered trump's
really sort of
disgusting flagrant out racism he's
wrapped it in education education right
which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race that's the
fundamental problem for these parents
and this anti-crt movement they don't
like the way whiteness is being
portrayed
in these new more inclusive lessons this
wasn't about those pocketbook issues
this was about
how white kids feel talking about what
black kids go through the subtext of all
this was we can't let these black and
brown people run the country glenn
younkin running
on critical race theory that he knew hit
a chord around race i think all the crt
stuff is trumped up dog whistling some
of it was
uh dog whistle racism the dog whistle
messaging that you saw yunkan
engage in during the course of the
campaign
well a real diversity of opinion on
msnbc and cnn you got to give them that
at least
white grievance they say white identity
politics white anger white backlash
interestingly online um the blame has
been placed
more specifically at the feet of white
women
bigoted dirt bag wajahat ali with the
daily beast published an article
yesterday afternoon titled you damn
karen's are killing america
now i've long argued that karen is a
racial slur originally when i said that
people laughed at me for saying so uh
they're not laughing quite as much
anymore because the karen thing
as we see is not a lighthearted jab at
certain types of white women it has
become and indeed always was
a label that non-white people use to
describe any white woman they don't like
wajahat ali's article is nothing but a
long insult laden diatribe targeted at
all white women
he despises the entire group and is not
shy about saying so
it's impossible to imagine any white
commentator using a common black female
name as a pejorative and then writing an
article with this kind of tone and
message this is a treatment reserved for
whites and especially white women
and in fact it's downright tame
compared to what you find in less
mainstream corners of the internet for
example here's a viral video from some
random caucasia phobe i'm going to call
them now
again again letting white women know how
much he hates their guts and again
feeling perfectly comfortable saying all
of this out loud
dear white women what the [ __ ] is your
purpose huh what the [ __ ] is your
purpose huh what the [ __ ] is your
purpose other than ruining the
[ __ ] casserole what the [ __ ] is
your purpose other than voting against
your better interests what the [ __ ] is
your purpose other than running the
[ __ ] holes with expires closed
cast no damn what that's been expired
since 2010 talk about i want to speak to
your manager i want to buy something for
my timothy it should be silly good it
seems like every year white women just
keep getting worse aren't they getting
worse if you look at the electorate
white women continue to vote for
republicans every year it keeps going up
it keeps going up so my question is why
should we trust a lily white hoe white
women can't be trusted well no kenny
don't be so mean to them you know white
suburban women are going to get it
together no you're not if you ain't got
it together then you ain't going to get
it together now y'all didn't even vote
for your own white sister hillary why
the [ __ ] should we trust white women and
the thing that's really pissing me off
is we continue to cuddle these white
women while we keep [ __ ] on black
women we keep known black voters but we
always put all this stock into white
women that are never gonna show up for
us that's continue to vote against their
own better interests
just can't imagine man i can't imagine
why um any white woman wouldn't want to
vote alongside that guy
it's a mystery
now the most common conservative
response to the claims of white
grievance and white backlash
is to deny them and insist that you know
race had nothing to do at all
with the results in virginia but that's
not really true and we shouldn't pretend
that it is now racism had nothing to do
with the results
but race itself
even white grievance and white backlash
quote unquote did indeed play a part and
rightfully so
the fact that white voters are
shy about admitting this only shows how
deeply ingrained anti-white racism has
become there shouldn't be anything
embarrassing or controversial about
saying out loud yeah i'm white and i
don't like anti-white racism and i will
vote against it
no member of any other race would
hesitate to admit that they find racism
targeted against them objectionable and
that they're motivated to take action
against those who display it
virginia was not merely about race the
broader issue was education but one of
the major things that voters in virginia
wanted to extricate from their school
system is anti-white racism specifically
anti-white racism and we need to be
specific about that
this is not racism in general that you
find
mainstream systemically in the school
system not racism in general it is
anti-white racism
not any other kind of racism anti-white
parents do not want their children to go
to school
and learn white guilt and self-loathing
yeah
that's correct
i have a grievance against that as a
white person i do
why shouldn't i
another viral tweet this from a woman
named morgan kilday says in an
accusatory tone it says
white women vote to protect their white
sons that's it
now she means this as a criticism
but that only shows how deeply embedded
is her own anti-white bigotry the left
as a whole is hopelessly lost in the fog
of its white-hating bigotry they can't
see
uh
up or down
that now they accuse white mothers
accuse white mothers
of wanting to protect their sons as
though this is somehow shameful as
though white mothers ought to respond no
no that's that's absurd i would never
dare protect my sons they're white after
all to hell with them
yes white mothers want to protect their
white sons
of course white mothers want to do that
just as black mothers want to protect
their sons and asian mothers want to
protect theirs and so on for all mothers
of all races and ethnicities
likewise white people in general want to
protect themselves and their families
from all forms of bigotry and hatred
that might be targeted at them
they are going to be less likely to come
stand by your side if you spew racial
insults and invective in their direction
the democrats have spent years shouting
into a bullhorn white people are evil
scum they're the source of all that's
wrong in the world die whitey die
then they look with shock and horror and
shake their heads in disappointment as
fewer white people line up to vote for
them
i mean they're sitting there with the
bullhorn white people are terrible and
then white people walk away they say
what are you walking away for oh you
must be racist
the way they see it
white people do not have the right
to self-preservation period
don't have the right to it
we should not be motivated by any desire
to protect or defend ourselves in fact
we shouldn't even be using words like we
and our at all
that's the way they see it
as a white person to even say the word
we in reference to other white people
is controversial and provocative
it's a racist dog whistle
because we're not supposed to notice our
race
or have any sense of racial identity at
all
everybody else on earth can't everybody
but not white people
the only time a white person is allowed
to notice their race
or have any sense of racial identity
it's an is in a strictly negative way so
we can look at our skin and say
i am white and i am ashamed
shame on me
but we cannot say
i am white
and i deserve to be treated with respect
and dignity that we're not allowed to
say
the latter thought process is deeply
troubling says the media it's
problematic
it really worries them
it worries them that there are some
white people out there who aren't ready
to to throw themselves into a fire
it's white grievance they say
well you're damn right it is we have a
grievance
and our grievance is against you
rabid foaming at the mouth bigots
we don't want to vote for your side if
it means we must bow in shame and
submission and we certainly don't want
you anywhere near our children
kids have enough identity crises foisted
upon them by the culture already they
don't need racial self-loathing on top
of it
so white grievance white backlash sure
absolutely well deserved
and we aren't the ones who owe an
apology here either now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
very happy to introduce an incredible
app that everyone who buys gas needs to
know about get upside is what it's
called my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first philip that's up to 50 cents that
you're getting back
on your fill up this is free money it's
as simple as that why would you leave
free money sitting there on the floor
doesn't make any sense don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code walsh to get up
to 50
uh rather 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash back gets
added to your account right away you
don't have to go through any great you
don't have to climb a mountain or
anything to go find it at the top of
mount they just send you the uh the
money they send right to your bank
account paypal egift card for amazon and
other brands as well
it's as simple as that so here's what
you need to do download the free get
upside app and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank that's codewalsh the get
upside app all right we'll let
mediamatters have a lot of fun with that
as i'm sure they will you know the other
thing by the way that i think
has gone
that i cannot allow to go unnoticed is
that i think
what really swung the election at the
end of the day when it comes down to it
what this is really about is is really
the sweet baby gang i i think
and i only say i don't even really mean
it as a joke i actually think the sweet
baby gang is is what uh
made the difference in that election
sweet baby gang
the most important movement
of the 21st century
i just have to find a good place for uh
for our
compound
and by the way what flavor kool-aid do
you guys all prefer cherry is it well
just let me know in the comments
um all right so biden announced speaking
of a kool-aid announced that the pfizer
shot will be rolled out officially for
kids five to eleven we knew this was
coming
uh we we you know we've been
told about this we've been promised or
threatened depending on how you look at
it
that the the vaccine will be made
available for kids as young as five
and now joe biden is very excited to
tell us that uh you can finally bring
your kids in and jab this substance
right into their bodies uh and he
expects that we will all be lining up to
do so here's joe biden making the big
announcement
today is a great day for american
parents and american families and
american children
we've taken a giant step forward to
further accelerate our path out of this
pandemic
after months of rigorous and independent
scientific review
the food and drug administration the fda
authorized
and the center for disease control and
prevention the cdc recommended a cova 19
vaccine for children ages 5 through 11.
for parents all over this country this
is a day of relief and celebration
after almost 18 months of anxious
worrying every time the children to your
child had a sniffle or started to cough
well you can now protect them from this
horrible virus because that would always
worry that was coming along
28 million more young americans are now
eligible for the protection of a vaccine
and my administration is ready we're
ready from day one today
organized and have a plan
for this vaccination's launch
as soon as next week we'll have enough
vaccine and enough places and parents
will be able to schedule appointments to
get their kids their first shot
and we've already secured enough vaccine
supply for every single child in america
ages 5 through 11.
oh that's good news well you can you go
ahead and hang on to that biden
why don't you take them all yourself how
about that that's my suggestion
no you go ahead you could take all all
my kids i got four kids and you can have
all their doses
but you you could take those
biden says
months and years of anxious worry every
time a child has a sniffles or a cough
um no
that's not the case for me because i'm
not a paranoid lunatic and i also
understand the science
behind this which has been very clear
from the beginning
that covet is almost no threat to kids
whatsoever almost
there's a a list a enormous a gigantic
list of things
that are far more threatening to kids uh
than covid and many of those things that
are higher on the list
are things that most parents don't even
think about at all
so no i haven't been worried at all in
fact my kids had a sniffles and a cough
last week
and i didn't worry about it at all guess
what i didn't get them tested
yeah i don't every time my kid has a
cough or a sniffle i don't run out and
get them covered tested i don't
i'm not living you know i don't live
that way because that's crazy that's
insane
the people get colds kids get colds that
still exists in the world
in fact kids are getting colds a lot
more now than they were before because
we put them in masks or a lot of people
put their kids masks i didn't put mine
in but uh people put their kids in masks
a lot locked them in a house for two
years
and now their immune systems are shot
and so they're going to get a lot of
colds
you get a panic that it's covered every
single time every time your kid has a
sniffle
lock everything down quarantine them
quarantine yourself call out of work i
don't think so
no i don't get them cover tested um i'm
not gonna get in the shot i'm not
and if that makes you angry or upsets
you or if you think it's reckless or i'm
glad that you feel that way i'm glad
you're upset about it
because it's not gonna happen
and now the real question
is uh
will the biden administration
try to mandate this try to do something
similar to what they've done
mandating it for adults
will they attempt to do this on the
federal level
for kids five you know
down to the age of five
that's the question
now in some places like in san francisco
and and in deep blue places they've
already
instated some mandates like this but
you know you can get away with that
you can get away with a lot of things in
san francisco okay a whole lot of things
um but i will tell you right now
and this is um
this is a yeah this is a this is a
threat okay
or take it as a warning
you
you try to pass any kind
of nationwide mandate on kids you try to
tell parents
outside of these deep blue areas where
everyone is completely insane outside of
those areas you try to tell parents that
they have to allow you
to inject a substance into their
children's bodies you have no idea what
is coming it'll make the the school
boards look tame by comparison
because what you should have learned
from the school board meetings
is that you don't mess with people's
kids
you know there are a lot of parents a
lot of people
who will give you a lot of leeway much
more leeway than they should
and they'll allow you to even infringe
on their own liberties more than they
should
and allow you to do all kinds of things
to them
but the moment you point to their kids
and say yeah bring the kid over here too
to get a piece of this
the moment you do
you
that
that's that is the line in this it's not
it's not in the sand it's in concrete
that is a line drawn in concrete
for millions of people
and you you try to go to this extent
depriving
parents
of over
of their of their parental rights in in
in this most fundamental way
depriving them of the ability to decide
what happens to their kids what kind of
substances are put into their bodies
you're going to reap the whirlwind on
that
that's that is a statement of fact
it'll be a backlash um unlike anything
unlike anything uh that that we've seen
before
um and that and that is something that
will cut across just like in virginia
despite what what they tried to tell us
this was not a far right
movement there might have been plenty of
people who are on the far right i
proudly will will call myself on on the
far right
you know who were involved there but
i was there in virginia myself i talked
to i talked to plenty of people
and many of them were were basically
non-political or even or even previous
to this would have identified themselves
as liberal
but they don't like it when you mess
with their kids
you try to do that with the vaccine
mandate any kind of vaccine mandate to
kids
you're going to have a coalition
of
furious parents on your hands all across
the country that's what's going to
happen
all right next um the media is on to our
game guys there we
we've seen several articles like this
here's from the daily dot
um
wondering
fretting
accusing the daily wire of uh of you
know somehow
influencing the results of the election
says republican glenn younkin will be
the next governor of virginia his win
over democrat terry mcauliffe is seen as
a stinging rebuke to democrats ahead of
the 2022 midterm elections
while there's plenty of blame and credit
to go around in any election many
believe the electoral came down to one
thing a daily wire story
and it talks about the the story that
we're all familiar with
and then uh goes on and on
and then finally at the end it says this
for months the daily wire has
relentlessly pushed stories about
critical race theory in the virginia
governor's race the day before the
election the republican state leadership
committee used the outlet's mailing list
in a last-minute fundraising pitch for
yunkan many consider it unethical
listen many consider it unethical for
media outlets to function as an
apparatus of a political campaign
well
we're not anybody's apparatus
but
that is a
it's obviously a hilariously ironic
statement
coming from anyone in the left-wing
press
many consider it unethical for media
outlets to function as an apparatus of a
political campaign yeah
you're right it is
and as it happens democrat political
campaigns have the apparatus of the
entire corporate media
and that includes by the way
media outlets who pretend to be
objective
now
we we
we don't hide from the fact that we have
a point of view
at least on the commentary side of
things i'm the daily wire i don't hide
from it at all i have a very clear point
of view and i i want to push my point of
view i'm very upfront about that
and yet you know one of the main one of
the primary differences here
is if we're talking about you know nbc
nightly news or something
that where they're pretending unlike me
or i will straightforwardly say i'm not
objective
and don't pretend to be
you watch a news anchor over at nbc
nightly news or abc news or whatever or
you go to nbcnews.com
and you read one of their news articles
you know they are pretending to be
objective
this is all under the guise of
objectivity
i'm not i'm not worried about people
who are who are unobjective who are
subjective who are biased and admit to
it
you know i don't really care msnbc has
opinion programs that are pretty
straightforward about about having their
opinions okay fine
but it's when you have
bias that is not up front and honest
about what it is
and that's the other thing media bias is
not a new is not a new phenomenon either
i mean go back and look at old newspaper
clippings from uh you know the 19th
century from the civil war era
and you're going to find that the media
was heavily partisan and always has been
the difference with with a lot of these
corporate media outlets is that they
don't admit to it
they lie about it
and that's what makes it a problem
and you know this is this is maybe the
most absurd claim that we're hearing
from
from the left-wing media which is the
entire corporate media
you know the way that they try to
they are trying to position this in fact
i was just i don't remember which outlet
had it was just reading a headline from
one of these outlets they're all the
same
claiming that republicans have an
enormous advantage
because they have
because they have a media apparatus on
their side
unlike the democrats who don't
it's the same thing they do with social
media now
claiming somehow
that the social media companies are
biased in our favor
of course what they what they really
mean when they say oh the the
republicans have the media on their side
or
conservatives have you know there's a
pro-conservative bias on social media
what they really mean
is that
um
conservatives still have some kind of
voice
in the media
and that we're still able to attract
some kind of audience you know we
haven't been entirely shut down on
social media we still exist on social
media
and that's what they have a problem with
until we have been completely wiped out
erased
sent into the hinterlands evicted from
uh from civilized society until that
happens
then they're going to continue talking
about how we have all these these great
advantages the advantage is that we have
some kind of voice at all they think we
should have no voice
all right um and once again they're not
honest about that either
okay
this is from the wall street journal it
says wearing a mask in situations with
high covet 19 risk makes medical sense
but what about covering up your face
just because you're embarrassed to show
it
with the transition to a post-pandemic
world some mental health specialists
worry about people who may have grown
dependent on masks to shield themselves
from human connection if it gets serious
enough the dependency amounts to a form
of social anxiety disorder they say
mask wearing this is according to niburu
watanabe as a tokyo psychiatrist
says mask wearing helps people
temporarily escape from tension and
anxiety but it also makes it easier to
feel isolated we humans cannot live
alone we live in a society communicating
with others
and then it goes on to talk about how
this is a especially an issue in in
asian countries like japan
where masking is even more widespread
than than it is here and people have
just
adopted it as a normal way of life and
in fact you hear
pro-massacres in this country pointing
to asia and say you know asian countries
they they just wear masks all the time
cobit or no covet so why can't we do the
same
well here's one of the reasons why we
can't do the same
it's um
putting everything else aside
we are psychologically mentally
destroying people
we're supposed to be human beings
and being able to show your face in
public
being unafraid to breathe fresh air
being able to communicate with another
person where you can both see each
other's faces that's a fundamental it's
a fundamental aspect of human existence
and so yeah it matters to take away a
fundamental aspect of human existence
but it's just another one of those
things that those of us on the same side
of this question
have been making this point all along
that this is not psychologically healthy
to have people walking around in masks
all day
you know
um it's not it's not it this this is not
a way to live a a well-rounded fully
human
life where you where you have
you know where you were you were walking
around as this kind of faceless entity
interacting with other faceless entities
and for months and months and months
we've been condemned and mocked
for making this point
who cares about psychological health
who cares about the fundament
fundamental aspects of human existence
who cares
this is all about physical safety
um but in fact it does matter because we
are human beings and we're not robots
yeah i mentioned
a couple days ago a scene that you know
i've seen before and
many of us have seen but
to the point where it almost gets normal
and you hardly notice it but but but we
don't want it to be normal we don't want
to get to the point where
you know we we breeze right past it so
when i was hiking with my wife up in the
mountains in north carolina
[Music]
and you know we're out in the woods
and it's also a foggy kind of misty kind
of cold day which i think is perfect
weather for hiking but a lot of people
don't feel that way so it was um
you know we parked in the parking lot
near like the visitor center and there
was there were no other park cars in the
parking lot there was nobody else around
and um for the you know almost nobody
else
so we're hiking these mostly empty
trails and then a woman walks by on a
mountain in the woods outside
nobody else around and she has a mask on
her face
this this is someone as i've said all
along this is someone who's whose brain
has been broken they have been
psychologically
destroyed
i mean if you were to stop and talk to
this woman
um
and and ask her like what are you doing
why why do you
have that mask on
what do you think is going to happen to
you what what function do you think that
mask is serving for you right now
how exactly
do you think you might get covered in
the woods while you're walking through a
trail
yeah
look i i know in fact i've just i just
read that that the deer
are especially susceptible to covet so
yeah but so do you think a deer is going
to run up and cough in your face
is that why you have it on
walk me through the process
the mental process you put that mask on
in the morning before you left your
house and i'm sure you put it on before
you left your house and then drove in
the car with it too
what were you thinking to yourself
what purpose did this serve now if you
were to have that conversation
well it wouldn't be a conversation you
wouldn't be able to have a conversation
because they wouldn't have any answer
they have become it's it's it would be
like asking
you know a heroin addict who's just
about who's about to stick the needle in
his arm and going up to him and saying
why are you doing that you know what's
what's the logical reason for doing this
walk me through your logical steps well
there is no logical reason
he's uh he's an addict
and we've got a lot of people now who
are addicted to masking
and that is as it turns out that does
matter but we have to wait
you know we have to wait for the experts
we have to wait for the so-called
experts to make these points and then
the rest of us are allowed to
as always the non-experts
are months and months ahead of the
experts
so the non-experts can make common sense
observations
and then be mocked and derided for it
and a year later 14 months later the an
expert could come along and say you know
what
that's actually correct and well they
don't say that no they pretend like it
was their idea hey i just i just
realized something
maybe this isn't great for people's
psychological mental health
especially when we're in the middle of
what we're told is a mental health
crisis
and there's a there's a suicide epidemic
which there is
and people who are suicidal and
depressed they already feel
isolated in the world
they already feel as though they're not
noticed they feel disconnected from
other people
and so making them literally faceless
interacting with other faceless entities
that's probably not the best thing for
them
now we had to wait for the the experts
to tell us that and then we were allowed
to
to agree with it
all right um
let's see
we also there speaking of being in the
mountains this one the new york post it
says a hiker lost on a mountain in
colorado ignored repeated calls from
rescuers later explaining that they had
been unfamiliar with the phone number
the person was reported missing after
they didn't return from an expedition
search crews canvassed the area the
following day but couldn't find the
hiker the team then tried calling the
hiker but were unable to reach them the
hiker apparently wandered off the trail
and spent the night looking for it after
24 hours lost they found their way out
and made it to the car
the person apparently didn't know that a
search team had been looking for them
the subject ignored repeated calls
because they didn't recognize the number
so they were lost in the woods for 24
hours you know it's a pretty it's a
it's a decent amount of time to be lost
in the woods you gotta you gotta go
through at least one night in the woods
by yourself
they have their phone and it works and
they're getting calls on the phone
they look at the calls and say ah you
know i don't want to i don't recognize
the number it might be a telemarketer or
something probably calling about my car
warranty
i'm not gonna pick up
i i respect that i really do as someone
and i would probably do the same you
know
as someone who is i am steadfastly
opposed to
really phone calls of all types i don't
care who it's from
there's just no reason
there's almost no good reason
to to pick up the phone and actually
call someone these days
whatever you want to say
you know if you have just a and most of
the time when someone calls you
right they really have
one piece of information they want to
express they want to communicate to you
they've got about one sentence worth of
content that they need to bring to your
to your
attention and so they call you on the
phone
and five seconds later they've imparted
that information to you
but now you're still on the phone with
them and so you feel like you have to
say oh okay well thanks for telling me
that
um
so what else is going on and then you
have this awkward exchange
and telephone conversations are already
even more awkward than they need to be
because you're deprived of
you know uh body language you can't see
the other person
which means that you can't have a normal
you know person-to-person conversation
there can be pauses you don't have to
talk the entire time
but on a phone there can't be any pause
at all pause is excruciating so you got
to fill that you have to just keep
filling it with more and more talking
which means that the conversation goes
on longer and longer when there's no
reason for the conversation to begin
with
text message email
that's all you need
and if you really feel like you have to
have a conversation with me then come
talk to me face to face
and if we're not in the same state and
you can't talk to me face to face then i
guess i just will never talk to you
again that's the way it has to go
all right now let's get to our comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
frederick wilde says matt walsh really
is a detriment to the right he's petty
and mean-spirited as in the cheap
lipstick shot against mcauliffe in a way
that's just as reprehensible as the
screeching of racism by the left
whenever anyone disagrees with them he's
an old-style republican with no sense of
fair play and honest engagement and i
don't want him on our team with all of
his constant invective and dirty tricks
i thought
isn't my constant invective and dirty
tricks isn't that my whole charm
if i have any
the only exception i'll take with with
you on this frederick is um that doesn't
make me an old-style republican
no that makes me a new style
conservative
old-style republican is certainly not
that
um
led zeppelin says matt is completely
right about being an adult living at
home with your parents
unfortunately these days there's a lot
more to it as a young man right out of
high school i moved out of my house and
stayed lived on my own for almost a
decade it's a really good experience i
think everyone should go through then my
dad lost his job and got very sick bills
were getting very tight and it didn't
make sense for me to pay my rent and his
mortgage i moved back in we didn't lose
the house everything has been fine since
but let me tell you as a 30 year old guy
when you tell that to people nobody
believes that's why you live at home
and i don't blame them but i love my
family and i don't know if any household
can make it on a single income these
days
well yeah that's a completely different
situation right you you were living on
your own you moved out of the house
you moved back in to take care of your
parents that's obviously to me a very
different sort of situation
um
just as there are
you know adults who have their elderly
parents come and move in with them
nobody would accuse them of being
childish or you know having extended
adolescence because they had their
elderly sick parents move in with them
um that's a very different thing
the issue i was talking about and the
real issue in our society are adults who
have never lived on their own and stay
with their parents as adults so that
their parents can take care of them
now we know there could be some
exceptions there i mean if you're if you
yourself are very sick or you know there
could be situations but
for the most part um
as you become an adult
you should
develop the skills and the ability and
the desire
to take care of yourself and to be
independent
that's part of being an adult
the problems when you have adults living
at home
for these extended periods of time
as as dependents i mean you should not
be
with
you know in most cases
you should not be a 25 year old
dependent
on your parents
and again you shouldn't want to either
that's the other thing i don't i don't
understand like i when i was um
when i was a young man i i wanted to
leave the home not because i hated my
home or i hated my parents
i craved independence i wanted to
be out there in the world doing my own
thing and making my own way that's a
desire that i had and i just don't
understand
all these people who lack that desire
especially young men
you know it's not natural it's
talk about not being psychologically
healthy
you should want that
all right um
charles says normally i skip over the
ads on the other daily wire shows but i
look forward to yours with youthful glee
the subtle and dry sarcasm you read
these ads with is the highlight of the
show spg for life i don't know what
you're talking about
charles i have no idea what you what you
mean
um
eamon says
or rather margot says matt i can't
believe you let your daughter dress up
as a witch for halloween
they are real and evil and enemies of
the church
very disappointing for a man with a
cairo tattoo
um
no the the witch with the pointy hat and
the broom they are not they are not real
that's a fictional character margot i
appreciate your concern
for my for my
eight-year-old daughter's witch costume
okay she was not demonically possessed
by wearing it
um she's she is not now engaging in the
black arts
okay she's not becoming a satanist
that's a fictional character
now is demonic possession real yes
but that's when a little kid dresses up
with a witch with a pointy hat you know
green face long nose and a broom that's
not what they are
trying to portray so
but again thank you so much thank you so
much for your concern about my kids
halloween costumes and for um you know
making your opinion known it's very very
valuable feedback and i will
make sure to ignore it eamon says look
i'm not a father yet so maybe i don't
know but i would be concerned with the
morals of killing the boyfriend in
church we're taught murder is the second
biggest sin you can commit
above breaking the law of chastity no
i'm not concerned with prison that's
temporary family
family is eternal
uh he's talking about the case of the
father who
according to the reports the father's
daughter was um
was
sent into was was sex trafficked we
became a sex slave
and the boyfriend is what's is who sold
her into sex trafficking the father went
and rescued his daughter
and then when he was told that the
boyfriend was responsible he tracked the
boyfriend down and beat him with a
cinder block and stabbed him to death
and dumped him in a car in the trunk of
a car where he remained for uh for a
year and then unfortunately was found
and so now that the father has been
charged with murder um
no i um
yeah i will again reiterate i don't see
what this father did wrong
um
but i think there are times when your
your fatherly
duty takes over
and you're called you know
the other thing we have to we have to
keep in mind here
is that people have lost all faith
in the justice system
we really we really don't have a justice
system anymore there is no system of
justice
and so you know you could say well no
let the you know let the authorities
take care of it they'll bring him to
justice we have no reason to think that
will ever happen
and so you're going to find you'll
probably find cases like this more and
more
but no if i if i were on the the jury
there's no way i would uh you know maybe
you convict this guy he dumped the body
in a part in a car
and left it in the woods
so maybe convict him of a parking
violation so you're right there were
some crimes committed probably a parking
violation maybe you get them on
improper disposal of a corpse and so you
hit him with a misdemeanor for those
and um slap him on the wrist maybe give
him a 25 fine and then send him on his
way
all right
another one says
uh at least matt stopped degrading 12
year olds ever since a 12 year old said
he listened every day got to speak out
as a 12 year old listener since matt has
been kind of rude to me and my homies
lately no i don't degrade 12 year olds
at all i degrade adults who who act like
12 year olds but 12 year olds are
perfectly
uh within the right stack like 12 year
olds in fact i would as a 12 year old i
would encourage you to act like a 12
year old because this is your only
opportunity to act like a 12 year old
so just to clarify that but thank you
for listening
um
and uh let's see what else we got
isaac says matt will you keep your
christmas decorations up until january
9th per the liturgical calendar
yeah well we keep them up um
that long per the lazy calendar
you know it's and then and then i guess
i'm pretty sure that's why the
liturgical counter goes to january 9th
with the christmas season
just because people are kind of lazy i
want to take the decorations down
then after the fact we figured out a
liturgical reason that's not the real
church history at all but um i i would
be lying we do keep it up longer i'd be
lying if this if i said this was purely
out of uh
you know solidarity with the liturgical
calendar it's also just it's also just
laziness and as we all know taking down
the christmas decorations is not as fun
as putting them up until you put it off
for that reason and so that's my that's
my moment of honesty for you one of my
favorite things to talk about is
mortgage refinancing and finally we have
a sponsor that allows me
to get into this
american financing is what it's called a
mortgage refinance might be the smartest
move you make all year it could save you
thousands of interest maybe help pay off
your loan sooner even allow you to
access cash but to really capitalize on
a mortgage refinance you must be sure
you're choosing the right loan with the
right lender that's why i recommend
american financing america's home for
home loans for over 20 years they've
been a mortgage industry leader offering
competitive rates low monthly payments
and custom terms without ever charging
upfront or hidden fees it's a no
pressure experience that's focused on
you and it just takes a 10 minute call
to get started that's it you'll get a
but you might stay on for even longer
if you love talking about mortgage
refinancing as much as i do you'll get a
free mortgage review and we'll learn
about ways to save up to a thousand
dollars a month you may even skip two
mortgage payments along the way but
you've got to call america financing and
you've got to do it right now
866-569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
and
almost forgot
americans are the targets of the
corporate propaganda machine known as
the mainstream media and it's time we
start waking up to the constant
deception and start exposing the
skeletons they keep locked firmly in
their closet daily wire is doing
everything possible to bring you the
truth every single day especially with
our recent foray into investigative
journalism our mission to bring the
facts front and center is going strong
the talents of our journalists is
unparalleled like luke rosiak who broke
the loudoun county sexual assault story
and um we watched his excellent work
along with the work of journalists like
christopher rowe ruffo affected real
change in the virginia election um and
also me am i on here okay
i'd love to add that on there because
you know me also um
and but really there's real change
happening in virginia but investigative
journalism is expensive which is why so
few media companies do the work this is
also why we need your support for as
little as four dollars a month you can
help us keep exposing the truth and
reclaim the narrative every new member
that joins our ranks strengthens our
ability to build up our investigative
reporting team if you want to join us in
the fight go to dailywire.com subscribe
and use code realnews to get your fix of
real news today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation um i'm
going to be very petty
granted this segment is almost always
petty you know i really could call the
segment five minutes of pettiness and
that would probably capture the spirit
of what i'm doing here but any case i
i'm feeling especially petty today after
driving into work this morning
and the problem with driving to work
every morning is that i live in
nashville
and though the people of nashville are
wonderful in many ways
they are not wonderful on the road this
town is populated by all of the world's
worst drivers
i don't know if bad drivers come here so
they so that they can be with their own
kind maybe nashville has become
something of a mecca for incompetent
motorists they come here on pilgrimages
many die along the way
or maybe after coming here good drivers
become bad
is there something in the water
is there something in the tennessee
whiskey
now i suppose there probably definitely
is something in the whiskey that would
make you a bad driver maybe i've just
solved the riddle i don't know this is a
question for psychiatrists and
anthropologists to study all i know is
that as i drive into nashville
i get a literal front row seat to
witness every bad driving habit every
single morning ramped up by a factor of
10. so just to give you an example the
kind of thing
you might encounter as you travel the
highways and byways of our lovely town
i have on multiple occasions
witness people screech to a halt on the
highway
i mean a dead stop from 70 to zero
so they don't miss their exit
i saw a guy once blow past his exit
screech to a stop
drive onto the shoulder and reverse on
the shoulder back to his exit
i witnessed this because i was the guy
right behind him
the guy who if not for my own incredible
skill i'm the only skilled driver in the
entire state by the way if not for that
i would have rammed right into him
killing him and far more tragically
myself
but he didn't believe that i existed now
for him
the other drivers are mere phantoms
they're aberrations we exist only in the
theoretical he is the only corporeal
life form on the road which is why he
can do whatever he wants and be as
reckless as he wants without fear of
colliding with another solid object
that's how he views it anyway unless
until he learns otherwise and learns it
the hard way and lots of people in
nashville learn that lesson the hard way
every day
i drive about 10 miles to work and in
that 10 miles every day i pass three or
four accidents
every day
and that's if the weather is good if
it's bad or even just mildly unpleasant
the highways look like the walking dead
cars and bodies littered all over the
place a truck flipped upside down
someone's jeep is stuck up in a tree
somehow a guy in a motorcycle is like
dangling over the overpass
it would appear that as soon as the
first raindrop hits the windshield
people panic and just drive directly
into the nearest object
and this is all very distressing for me
because then i am in the unfortunate
psychological position of feeling
annoyed at all of these people even
though half of them may well be dead
i don't want to be annoyed at your pain
and suffering
i don't i don't like that
but you're making me late for work
and you should have learned to drive
before you got on the road
yes you know yet this is this is all
really i think a preamble to my main
point i could continue complaining about
nashville drivers for another 35 minutes
but i'm not sure how relevant that kind
of content would be to the average
non-national system my main point is
this
i could run all the worst driving habits
on my local roads but none of it is
unique to nashville
the volume and frequency is unique but
bad drivers are everywhere all over this
nation of ours and i have you know i
have i have to navigate around them
everywhere i go and the number one
habit
of bad drivers everywhere at least on
the highway
is that they don't know how to merge
i was almost killed yet again this
morning by a bad merger which is why
it's top of my mind and i'll tell you
what happened
i was driving along on the highway
preparing to get off on my exit
see i had already positioned myself in
the rightmost lane because my exit was a
mile ahead and i wanted to be ready to
take it when the time came i didn't stay
in the left lane until my exit was 25
feet away and then attempt to cut across
four lanes of traffic i didn't do that
you see i was already in the right lane
before the exit comes
but as i was driving in that right lane
anticipating my exit somebody in the
merge lane entering the highway from the
entrance ramp just before my exit
suddenly jerked onto the highway into my
lane going about 15 miles an hour i had
to once again slam on my brakes
saving my life and undeservedly his i
then hit my horn in retribution and
shouted you know you dumbass learned to
drive or whatever but he couldn't hear
me no doubt he went on his merry way
oblivious to the fact that he just had a
near-death experience
for this guy this probably happens every
day his life is saved every day and he
doesn't even know it
now this idiot made the same mistake
that the majority of drivers who are
also idiots seem to make
somehow you know we require that new
drivers go through a driving test
but merging doesn't make it into the
exam
and the result is that the highway is
filled with suicide bombers and kamikaze
pilots who plunge into traffic taking
their lives into their hands every time
they do it
merging is an art
almost entirely lost in our world today
so let me give you the tutorial
when you're entering the highway
you will notice
that the other cars on the highway
they're all going fast
and this it would seem frightens the
average driver and so they come to a
dead stop in the middle of the merge
lane waiting for a hole in the traffic
not realizing that the hole in traffic
this is physics
moves with the traffic
and they then insert themselves into
that gap at a speed about 90 percent
slower than the rest of the cars on the
road
then comes the accident and people die
and worst of all i am inconvenienced
here's the way it's supposed to work
when merging into traffic
you increase your speed
go faster get up to the speed of the
traffic on the road you have a whole
lane remember usually a merge lane will
extend for dozens of feet or more so
make use of that lane that's been given
to you for that purpose speed up pick
your spot seamlessly merge into that
spot while going the same speed as the
cars in front and behind you if you do
it correctly nobody should have to hit
their brakes at all to accommodate you
if you're waiting for someone to let you
in thinking that you know they'll slam
on their brakes bringing traffic to a
standstill and roll out the red carpet
for you you're not approaching the
situation the right way it is your job
to assimilate yourself into traffic to
become one with the flow of traffic to
take your place on that great dance
floor that is the highway without anyone
else having to break their rhythm
that is your solemn and sacred
responsibility it's why there's a yield
sign in the merge lane not a stop sign
learn the difference
use suicidal maniac
now if all this is too complicated for
you and it is for some people
or if you find highways too intimidating
then stay home
save us all the trouble
save our lives and your own
otherwise i have no choice but to say
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today i
told you it's gonna be petty at the end
of the show thanks for watching thanks
for listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode
several elections changed the national
landscape the supreme court hears
arguments on the texas pro-life law and
san francisco suffers more fallout from
skyrocketing crime
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire